I see the mark on booth okay tomorrow
market Marc Anthony you good oh I'm
ready come on let's get these questions
we are gonna be with the judges is there
any question I should ask them from you
you're gonna be with the judges with
yeah Michelle all of them boo para Paul
Michelle car swinging in from me can I
calm let me crash that - oh you want to
ask them say ax them Vanessa wants to
know right now we how many episodes in
what what would you tell what advice
would you give her right now at this
very moment and you better specifically
save me don't meet girls wanna know come
on me in the one in the season 11 okay I
would have just said keep doing what
you're doing I'm she's kind of like she
ain't kind of just the narrator for this
season like she is the voice of the show
even beyond saying Kelly gotta pull
Michelle so we did that now we pumpkin
in it but I will so just do what you're
doing
I would tell van G to use the show like
a billboard I think people are falling
in love with her and so you know she
could still win this whole competition
right but she is winning in life every
time we get more of her on on an episode
so just just use it as a springboard
show people who you are when I supposed
to know just deep into the arm episode
what do y'all what are you because they
don't get to see what's going on
backstage and all that so listen it's
always important to be yourself you know
when we watch the audition reels
everyone a lot of the people are doing
what they think I would want from them
it's like no I want you to be yourself
because we want your unique originality
to really come to the competition and
listen if you're out there and you're on
the main stage and you're being
critiqued listen there's a reason we're
telling you that I'm looking at you and
I see round almost
it's about definition you want to see
the lines in the outfits so it's
literally a head and legs and the rest
is flowers note taken Michelle don't
hot-glue Vanessa to know quartet and
make sure Michelle don't read me all I
was thinking about is my stuff like
[ __ ] you better not go home thank you
Miss fancy I thanked myself
you